prochz mesdames et messieurs demander la
chanson de rue réclamer le succès du
jour
elle revient quelquefois nous parler
d'autresfis et puis d'un chanteur des
rus é usé la voix je voudrais vous la
dire attendez ça va venir elle était
pourtant facile à
retenir c'est une chanson qui commenceit
comme ça Tam Talam il y a pas de raison
pour que je m'en souvienne pas c'était
l'histoire d'un monsieur et d'une dame
vous alleer voir c'est à vous fendre
l'âme dans cette chanson qui raconte
comme que la passion ça vient mais ça
dure pas
t le monsieur pleurait la dame pleurait
tout le monde pleurait dans cette
chanson qui commençait comme ça
je sais bien cette façon ça ne dit rien
mais pardon fallait voir les pes-voix
qui tremblent des émotion et la foule
des amants qui vivaient leur roman en ce
tempsl au moins il y avait du sentiment
c'est une chanson qui commençait comme
ça il y a pas de raison pour que je m'en
souvienne pas dans cette histoire qui
racontait le drame
du désespoir d'un monsieur et d'une dame
toute la pati tenait dans ces mot
là quelle obsession je me rappelle plus
pourquoi à Monsieur pleurait une dame
pleurait tout le monde pleurait dans
cette chanson qui commençait comme ah
bon je me rappelles pas mais je me
rappelle d'une chose très nettement ça
je et alors il simit il qui est amoureux
il pleurait n'est-ce
pas pourtant l'histoire du monsieur et
de la dame soir après soir àer dans les
âes une provision de petits bouquets
d'amour c'est une raison pour qu'on se
rappelle un
jour qu'un monsieur pleurait une dame
pleurit tout le monde pleurait dans
cette chanson qui commençait comme ça
dans cette chanson qui comm
ah comme
ça